[Music]
that there's like few vying for the
potential that Caitlyn Jenner does sign
on to Dancing with the Stars rumors that
you and Mark are kind of like put your
name in the Hat for that with that with
that inspiring to come back for sure
I don't know I mean I think I'm up for
me I'm up for like any sort of challenge
that and one thing I pride myself not
myself I went fried dance with stars on
is taking chances and doing things are a
little bit out of the box and there may
be some things that you know you know
that are inspiring and that our brave
and so for me I say why not
absolutely you know I have to ask no
surprise I don't what I don't want
though but I don't want I don't know I
don't know what's going on because I
certainly won't be doing that again
we're you know mean we're up saying I'm
not doing it suddenly doing it I'm
either going to where I'm not going to
and I think you know we'll see what
happens so we've seen pictures with you
we should go friend ropes of course is
he gonna be joining on tour are you both
very busy schedule yeah he's an amazing
dance routine the number he comes on
that's actually like he wants to learn
how to dance so bad and we think that
with me being his girlfriend it would
happen
are you teaching him or does he have to
learn from somebody else no I was
actually funny we were we were cooking
and we like to like dance in the kitchen
when we're cooking and he's like so I
had this line dancing thing he pulls it
up on his computer and it's like these
people line dance again I'm like that's
they actually do the best tricks line
dancers but I was like let's do it like
this he's like but they say to do it
like that like
[Music]